[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce soir je vais vous emmener au voyage
puisqu'elle fait j'aimerais ou ce soir
leur chair ce voyage c'est vers une
technologie
cette technologie qui a changé ma
manière de fonctionner comme agnel et
travailler en tant que développeur de
mais sans plus attendre
nous allons d'abord effectuer n'importe
où même le bassin voilà cette image nous
visons le monde tel que nous en cette
scientifique de haut niveau
le mot ni le voyait dans sa peau toute
dimension la dimension croisé à
dimensions 3d sony une wahyono moon
avait ceux qui la vôtre a repris en
longueur en largeur et en profondeur un
peu un peu génial apparu sur cette année
qu'une tape lyon la sphère mode planète
nous avons commencé à nous et tombent
les populations humaines en rouge et nos
moins a vers un point b
ainsi nous avions commencé à communiquer
échanger et partager plus nous nous
éloignons les uns des autres
nous avons ressenti le besoin de
communiquer sur cette distance plus
longue
intelligent nous avons réfléchi nous
avons créé un très bon outil tel que le
télégramme
mais nous sommes parvenus grâce à crabes
ou téléphoniques
la première innovation majeure par le
domaine de la communication
ce téléphone s'est accompagnée c'est si
nous avons connu le premier téléphone
fixe nous avons connu le premier
téléphone mobile ainsi de suite
nous en sommes là aux matrones pas
seulement nos outils de communication
évoluées de la pierre taillée premier
outil de travail nous sommes pas face à
l'ordinateur aujourd'hui cependant nous
avons perdu une vision que nous avions
eu mon petit à petit nous avons au
diable d'imagés dans des écrans nous
avons commencé à passer toute mesure
n'est dans des écrans et nous croyons le
mois de mai non plutôt que d'appuyer un
paysage
antoine et nous l'admirons à travers
l'écran de nos téléphones portables
la technologie que j'aurais vous
présentez se nomme la réalité étendu la
réalité tant du ser 9,5 de trois
technologies
la réalité augmentée la merditude
actuelle et labiales et la réalité qui
tuait va vous permettre à l'époque
talent de vénalité des inscrits en
l'occurrence vous immerger dans des
environnements totalement digitaux route
des environnements 3d
vous serez donc coupé du monde et elle
engloutit venant notamment des de l'ocs
numériquement et vous pourriez avoir
assez à des expériences immersives ou
non la réalité augmentée quant à elle a
commenté le monter que le connaissez
mais ajoutée de l'information pour vous
permettre d'avoir accès aux informations
aux données dont la
besoin encore hier la réalité mixte
quant à elle par contre on chez la
réalité augmentée et se cacher la
réalité virtuelle défusionnées et nous
permettront d'avoir des informations
dans le monde réel mais en même temps
d'interagir avec cette information est
parfois avec des outils adaptés de
sentiers de retour avec leur menu
d'interaction avec des éléments 3d
comment accéder à tous ces outils
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui nous avons beaucoup d'outils
mais faut dire que nous sommes passés
sur cette étape là il s'agit là du
premier simulateur de réalité virtuelle
ou venir là aujourd'hui pour la réalité
virtuelle
vous avez des dates réalité actuelle
aucune chance au new year to american
réalité augmentée ou des lunettes de
réalité augmentée comme le x et pour la
réalité knicks vous avez des classes tom
le online ou le bas 10 points mais
l'outil qui reste aujourd'hui accessible
à tous et qui nous permet de bénéficier
de toutes ces technologies reste notre
téléphone portable d'un téléphone
portable
évidemment c'est une ironie je disais
qu'on est d'autant moins 25 blessés dans
des one de 10 est aussi que ça nous
permet de faire de la réalité donc
aujourd'hui nous avons des téléphones
très pressé voliez truffé de capteurs
qui nous permet d'avoir une fabrication
nous sommes actuellement au moins 8
milliards une personne fiable quand le
téléphone pas tous le besoin de faire
partie des technologies à tout compromis
comment l'utiliser pour la réalité tendu
aujourd'hui nous ne parlons plus
influent du lot lointain nous parle
futur
déjà là dans le domaine de l'éducation
salle de classe aujourd'hui il est
possible plutôt que d'apporter un bloc
de rennes et de le placer sur le bureau
du professeur et de fait faire le tour
de ce groupe à chaque élève il est
possible qu avec le téléphone portable
pour le téléphone portable pourrait
faire une et dias coup le voile
ou l'intérêt de voir les pays qui se
situe sous le bras et le pouvoir a mis
les bouchées ou afficher les
informations dans le domaine du tourisme
ou la technologie de la nec du zen très
répandue il sera par exemple aussi de
visiter un lieu touristique comme neuf
il a plus de contenu entier avec un
calme inhabituel
assis dans mon salon elles vont
bénéficier de ce voyage ou ans peut
encore revenir dans le pays aller par
exemple à la thématique ou à la peau et
fait le pari ou avoir des informations
sur cinq ou six monuments sur cette
dalle public sans avoir forcément besoin
d'un guide pour ce qui concerne la
médecine par exemple
aujourd'hui nous avons multiples
indications de la réalité pendu dans la
médecine etc ou d'anatomie ne seront
plus avec des poings liés au recul est
en danger
le moins à midi ça c'est le fémur non en
aurez une vue que chaque étudiant cuae
emmené chez lui à être téléphonie à une
habile au toucher et pouvoir fait figure
d'élément nous faisons la référence à
une citation de confucius easy chantant
j'oublie je vois je me rappelle je fais
je comprends donc là qu'il s'agit d'une
espagne en une réalité virtuelle par des
étudiants oui il est possible de pouvoir
avoir ce que les humains de le désosser
d'apprendre à l'est du lac de
l'expérience
les différents de différents sauts sur
elle même voir le bac munger qui ici n'a
pas eu envie de jouer à un jeu mais tam
sans avoir établi ici pas raison n'a pas
eu envie de jouer au 2e rallye c'est ce
travail
puis j'ai fait grâce à la réalité et
tendu qui m'a permis de créer le premier
jeu de awa ly ati pour 7,1 en réalité
augmentée
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui il est pleinement possible
aussi de faire des mots en réalité
virtuelle idéaux mois de vie rappelez
vous n'avez vous pas eu cette réunion à
laquelle vous avez besoin d'assister me
suis tellement outil de déplacement -
empêchement ne pouvais plus aller à
tokyo
aujourd'hui c'est possible de faire avec
des applications en réalité virtuelle
maintenant j'aimerais dire quelque chose
que je dis de 8,3 et que j'aimerais
partager avec eux ce soir
pour moi la réalité connue changerait
drastiquement la manière dont nous
accomplissons de taille tous les jours
mais pour ça qu'il faut qu'elle soit
accessible à tous on en part de marché
il ne cesse de s'accroître aujourd'hui
plusieurs développeurs web
plusieurs particuliers ou paiement sont
selon lui le marché de la réalité tendu
la main
le meilleur moyen est accompagnée et de
rendre cette technologie accessible à
tous ce serait dans un premier temps en
somme il consomme et les applications de
réalité augmentée dans nos différents
outils qui nous
reportage il suffisait de taper à des
échanges à schoder pourra être le type
d'habitation et st jean est consommé
pour en faire quoi partager de vulgarité
c'est à pinnacle ira mon amour un truc
super avec erick mombaerts se noue récup
les sept points tout ça dans le but de
s'approprier la technologie pour
commencer à créer des expériences et
ensuite un pacte ce travail schumi la
tonne de buts trois ans et je ne suis
pas besoin mais pour mieux accompagner
les personnes dans le silence régnant du
reality étendue j'ai pensé à une formule
qui est accessible à tous je les
appelais est intenable estime qu'un
simple afom qui nous permet de créer des
expériences réalité étendu sans avoir
forcément besoin de développeurs
le premier problème pendant aujourd'hui
lorsque vous avez une idée de réalité
augmentée une réalité de dialoguer avec
tout début leur faire trop souvent nos
campagnes vont en cours et qui s'y
connaissent mais qui n'ont pas le temps
d'apprentissage qui sont pour prendre un
pot et analyser cette plateforme
composée d'un site web une application
web qui permet de craignez pas de
respect en tout 7 et ensuite d'une
habitation où il pouvait lui a publié
pour permet aujourd'hui décrié des
espagnols
beauté accessible à tous suin importe
quels terminaux
c'est le voyage que je voudrais faire
deux fois j'espère que vous n'avez pas
été déçu merci pour votre attention
[Applaudissements]